add the drops and hope for the best
that's something many of us have done by
now but are rapid tests reliable it's an
imperfect
test
it's the best way to put it turns out
they aren't that great when it comes to
detecting omicron and its variants
they're not a perfect answer they're not
as good as our lab-based pcr test in
terms of the sensitivity in other words
making sure that that negative test is
truly negative test accuracy with past
variants was 80
but with omicron that's dropped to about
45
and it's not uncommon evan says to test
negative a few days into experiencing
symptoms and that's just because of that
unreliability that sensitivity is
lacking with some of the tests
certainly some of the common ones we use
here in ontario but for most of us rapid
antigen tests are our only tool
sometimes it's hard to get an
appointment to get a piece here which
are obviously more accurate but it's the
best tool we have to test ourselves at
home and give us the all information
that we can have so
if you feel unwell but still test
negative it's best to stay home
regardless if they have any symptoms at
all and they are all concerned that it
is covid related that they stay home and
they isolate the best they can meanwhile
evans says to keep testing a few days
into the illness to check for covid
rapid tests are good i don't want to
diss them but it's really important that
people understand that they certainly
have a lot of issues in terms of the
accuracy of their results and the best
way to test is to go beyond just the
nasal swab unfortunately when people get
these tests all of them have approved
for nasal sampling so people think
that's the only thing they should do but
actually swabbing throat cheek adds to
it and makes it a little bit more
accurate jessica nizhnik global news